would need to be right in order to move
back to the day i think it would be what
would have to be wrong with san diego
[Music]
happy saturday everybody oh it's a
beautiful day in san diego the sun is
finally out and
my plan today is have a perfect day in
san diego a lot of y'all are really
interested in what san diego has to
offer especially you know ever since i
moved from the bay to here and
i feel like i haven't really shown off
my city very much a lot of my friends
have like come visited from the bay and
they loved it so
i thought maybe i'd make a video about
that today as a vlog i love it here i
grew up here and i think just there's so
many fun things to do and
i also i'm treating this as like a
little treat and break for myself
to take myself to
my favorite parts of the city so i've
got this really cool ride today to use
to go around san diego so thank you so
much hyundai for sponsoring today's
video i will tell you more about their
new all-electric ioniq 5 in a little bit
so far i've driven it and it's great i
really like it so i'll tell you all
about the features so stick around for
that but first i am in liberty station
in san diego this used to be like a navy
barracks and now it's turned into this
whole like shopping
experience with food and
mostly food
and i'm gonna go get coffee because it's
9 48
and i haven't had my coffee yet and
there's a really good coffee shop here
so let's go
[Music]
got my coffee i'm just walking around
liberty station i love this place
there's just so much stuff to do it's
really close to downtown san diego so if
you're in the area and you're staying in
downtown san diego it's kind of like the
perfect spot to be there's all these
really nice like open green spaces
where you're gonna have a picnic there's
a whole liberty station public market
where there's a bunch of different food
places i just got coffee at my favorite
coffee place down here called monica
general they're shopping there's just so
much fun stuff to do like
places like this were hard to come by i
was living in the bay but now it's so
much easier and it's just it's free to
just hang out here so
i love coming here and look at how nice
the weather is and people are just
very kind now i am going to go to my
sister-in-law's house
meet up with scott there and then we're
going to go for lunch
oh thank goodness for san diego i feel
like just the amount of sun that i get
here is like so different and it
definitely helps with my mood and my
health and my well-being
hello
[Music]
say hello to my youtube people
i like this a lot i like the cars come
with this now
it's really like all the sounds are
really gentle
yeah very asian
oh it does close you found it
wow wow
scott has entered the chat
yo
what do you think it's nice
we're gonna go to lunch
and then
we'll kind of keep exploring i suppose
i'm so sure i have to like pull this
perfect day in san diego
with scott
commence
[Music]
just had lunch
oh i didn't get a shot of the skyline
i'm gonna go get it real quick okay
all right you guys we just finished
dinner and we're right now in la jolla
we're about to go to one of my favorite
beaches in san diego called wind and sea
it's just beautiful and gorgeous right
now we're just like chilling um it's
actually right down the street from
where scott and i got married the
darlington house but this neighborhood
is like so pretty but i wanted to take a
moment to thank the sponsor of this
video hyundai so hyundai was super
generous and letting me use this car
today to get around town all across san
diego and this is the all-new electric
ionic 5. it's actually really cool to
drive this thing because it's not even
out yet and getting the first sneak peek
at how this thing drives like dude i've
been driving this since like 9 a.m this
morning and it is a nice car so i think
you all can probably relate that like
when we think about the next car that
we're gonna buy it's probably gonna be
electric because it's much better for
the environment and it's really exciting
to see a lot more companies come out
with new electric cars let me just say
this one from hyundai is like really
like honestly so good it's got so many
iot capabilities it drives super well
the interior is really nice i really
like it so i know that when it comes to
electric cars range is one of the main
things that a lot of people think about
this car comes in both a rear-wheel
drive configuration as well as an
all-wheel drive one the rear-wheel drive
one has 300 miles of range and then the
all-wheel drive option has 269 miles of
range that's basically like a full tank
of gas on a regular sedan so the thing
about range and electric cars things are
getting so much better and this car
really has everything to offer in terms
of that and when it comes to charging
this car charges super fast you can get
60 miles of range in a five minute
charge or you can go from 10 to 80
battery in 18 minutes as far as features
and interior goes i really like it as
well the cabin itself is super roomy of
course this window all the way at the
top gives it that illusion as well but
there is actually more space because
you're not putting an engine in here
also it has all of the safety features
that you expect in a modern car and more
things like forward collision avoidance
assist blind spot collision avoidance
assist lane keeping rear occupant alert
driver attention warning surround view
monitor and highway driving assist and
yes it comes with android auto and apple
carplay and bluetooth connectivity and
like all the things that you would want
to have a really nice car ride oh not to
mention the key for this car is an nfc
card or you can also use the mobile app
to unlock the car so yeah very modern
car very like practical and seamless and
elegant design so i'll leave a link in
the description box down below so you
can check out and learn more about the
hyundai ioniq 5 and let me know in the
comments down below who you'd want to
take on a road trip with this car thank
you so much to hyundai for partnering
with me on this video it's been a blast
to drive and it's been really fun to
just like have this on my ride it
definitely makes my whole like perfect
day in san diego complete what do you
think about the car
hi scott approved scott approved scott
approved nice shall we go to the b show
yeah okay let's do it
[Music]
it's the ocean
congrats
it's so nice it's like two weeks from
christmas yeah
and it's like so freaking sunny and warm
clear skies today clear skies today look
at that
it's nothing but gorgeous ocean
[Music]
so
we're here
in little italy
because we want ice cream before dinner
but we were passed by this place
landini's pizzeria
which
[Music]
that's where we met kona for the first
time
because the rescue group that we
got him from
was doing a little like
what is it like a charity event huh
and so we met kona there a little puppy
he was 10 weeks old he was so cute
[Music]
salt and straw
should we get gelato or should we get
ice cream
[Music]
i guess certainly salt and straw is a
bay area thing
so i guess we brought a piece of bay
area into our perfect san diego day
that's not bad i don't know good ice
cream we have it everywhere now
you didn't though we would ever move
back to the bay area
really maybe what would need to be right
in order to move back to the day
i think it would be
more like what would have to be wrong
with san diego no no no with like my
family or something
um
no
that'll give me more out of necessity
than desire and more of your family like
we probably wouldn't move back there for
work again even if we live work for a
bay area company would you still do
i would fight to work remotely
like
not very closely
i finally got my ice cream on your
controller
i took like four bites out of i think
anyway
we hope you enjoyed
this perfect day in san diego
i feel like san diego there's many
different perfect days that you can
spend so if you'd like to see more of
these and leave a comment down below
but uh hopefully
we did a good job of representing how
great the city is
and how fun it is to be here and how
nice it is to come in december
so make sure to like and subscribe to
the channel
if you have any questions about life in
san diego let me know too
anything you want to add
bye everybody
[Music]
you